in our country I just used this as a
gross example and it's always easier to
pick on a country somewhere else but the
very fact that racism was not seen as a
major or central gospel issue till the
late 1960s is an absolute judgment on
the immaturity of Western Christianity
that it was not for most people a
transformational system it was for most
people a belonging system my belonging
system is better than your belonging
system and so what we thought about was
the container and we got so invested in
the container that many of our people
never got to the contents never got to
experience what it was all about
everything was the forms the forms the
forms my forms are better than your
forms
there's the Anglican form in the Roman
Forum and we'd waste time trying to
prove that one was better than another
instead of teaching people how to go
into the mystery and and that is always
formless it is always a mixture of
darkness and light where I can't explain
it with perfect certitude it took Julian
20 years of setting here in her cell in
Norwich England to comprehend one night
of religious experience may 8th 7th III
it's supposed to have happened in this
city and she enclosed herself in that
little spot for 20 years to try to
unpackage what had happened to her and
if you read her showings there's just
this constant ability to deal with
paradox and mystery and darkness and she
doesn't insist on certitude or answers
she can let God be God I want to end
this by giving you